دفعت ما تملك لتكون نسخه طبق الاصل من كيم
كارداشيان لتدفع في النهايه حياتها في
سبيل تحقيق ذلك
[موسيقى]
عارضه الازياء الامريكيه كريستينا جوركاني
تفارق الحياه نتيجه تعرضها لنوبه قلبيه في
مستشفى بولايه كاليفورنيا بعد ساعات قليله
من اجرائها عمليه جراحيه تجميليه تقارير
افادت بان كريستينا البالغه من العمر 34
عاما انفقت الاف الدولارات على عمليات
التجميل لدرجه انها لم تترك شيئا لتغطيه
تكاليف جنازتها عائله الراحله شاركت
متابعيها الخبر المحزن عبر وسائل التواصل
وفتحت صفحه لتلقي التبرعات منهم لدفع
تكاليف جنازه ابنتها المقرر اقامتها خلال
الايام المقبله في المقابل فتحت السلطات
المختصه تحقيقا في الظروف المحيطه بوفاه
كريستينا
[موسيقى]